teenage mutant ninja turtles this is uh
the the the movie is back they've
they've made uh they've made a teenage
mutant ninja turtle movie and you it
turns out was a big you were a big fan
as a kid i was yeah my i have an older
sister who was a big fan she was she's
12 years older so she was a teenager
when those came out and you know i
wanted to be just like her and she was a
super fan and then i became a real super
fan also and when i heard they were
making this movie i went out and sort of
campaigned for it and sent a bunch of
emails and was like you know you can
cast like i know everyone's ideal is
like emma stone as april o'neil the
reporter but i am the biggest fan and uh
it worked and i i got the part
that's how i got into sharktopus versus
terracuda
i'm sure you saw that it aired in early
august i'm sure oh i haven't seen it yet
you didn't see it you didn't you didn't
have a viewing party for when i was in
shark to push versus terracuda what's a
terracuda exactly
that's why you got to watch it
yeah anyway um oh a pterodactyl and a
barracuda yes wow that's very good okay
all right dangerous
yes
all of america watched it the ratings
were insane for that movie i don't know
where you were uh
but you know what you were not allowed
to watch a lot of television growing up
were you i wasn't i was my parents were
pentecostal and that's like a really
strict denomination of christianity in
the south and so we weren't supposed to
have televisions at all and my parents
were sort of like
the wild ones i guess of the group and
we did have one television and we were
allowed to watch um a couple of movies
and for some reason the two movies they
let me watch aside from ninja turtles
the other one was arachnophobia
i love it
i love their choices that they like
animals going berserk
like that's okay for you to watch but
nothing else from it but um i was
allowed to watch ninja turtles and then
i for some reason one day my dad let me
put on mtv when i was little and i i
fell in love with and don't judge me but
i fell in love with michael jackson i
was only five sure to me he was like an
epic yeah those were my those were the
things i was exposed to i was exposed to
as a child right
are you going to carry that through with
your kids and really limit their tv i
mean you like i'm going to limit this
educational and this show and stuff like
that but then other than that you're
going to lock it down no i'm going to
let them um watch movies but not
television that's good yeah i think
that's good yeah we really try and be
careful about that but they're then they
they have ways if we were not allowed to
watch tv technically when i was a kid
yeah and then we would watch tv and my
dad would come home and we would turn
off the tv that was the old days when
the tv would turn off but the screen
still had static on it and he would rush
in the room and feel the screen
and if he got an electric shock it was
like i'll get you all
what about the ninja turtles appeal to
you what was it about them um i feel
like
you know they're sort of based on the
four greek temperaments and so everyone
can see themselves in one of the ninja
turtles right uh and so for me i was
really taken with mikey i think he
reminded me of my dad but it's just fun
because you can see yourself and you can
see everybody that you know like
everybody
some of you are a raphael some of you
are a leo
you're probably a mikey no you're a
mikey with a little donatello because
you're a little phlegmatic
and
you're also a little sanguine those are
the temperaments oh okay i'm telling you
but part llama as well right
i do this a lot a little donatello